Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This going to be my flash episode 12 video.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it
yet.
So much Wally Barry training montage, teasing
all kinds a killer Frost up in the gorilla
city episode two-parter that's coming up.
So there's a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video sure to
click that bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything.
So I'll explain what's going on with the gorilla
city two-parter at the end of this because
it's going to be a break.
There's no new flash next week.
The gorilla city episode starts in two weeks.
So top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs.
There was so much stuff going on in this episode
in the villain was from the comics number
10 the flash versus kid flash foot race they
totally play of kid flash is overconfidence
it's all in good fun.
He just like really excited to be working
with Barry and Barry is naturally trying to
teach them some tricks.
It's a whole way of them showing you Wally
is naturally very talented he's amazing at
straight-line speed that is so flash season
one the problems that they face the villains
that they face are so much more complex than
the initial couple of episodes that we saw
way back in season one now the game is been
up big time.
So Wally is going to have to learn some more
nuanced flash tricks, and there's all kinds
of abilities they tease this for Cisco's character
to all kinds of abilities that you couldn't
even imagine that they haven't figured out
yet the speed force can do crazy things and
each speedster has their own type of abilities
that they learn just based on the way that
their brain works.
So no to speedsters are created alike.
Some of them have abilities that others don't
have.
So naturally Barry gets Wally with the phasing
that was one of the hardest things for Barry
to learn, but it was the reverse flash is
signature take down Brutus phasing his hand
right through someone's chest number nine
was all the funny bedding that everyone was
doing while they were racing we learn more
funny facts about earth.
19 bedding was banned after an incident with
VP Al Capone Abe Lincoln's on the hundred
dollar bill not Benjamin Franklin in Cisco
funds a couple more opportunities to name
drop Gypsy.
Just letting you know that he hasn't forgotten
about her and she's probably coming back on
the show before the end of the season number
eight enter the villain.
So this is Clive York and he's a character
from the comics the way they took him down
is a little bit different with ended up doing
is having to just bury him underground so
they couldn't touch anybody else.
So this solution was a little bit more sophisticated
phasing blood through him part of his storyline
was and making Julian feel guilty about being
the person to create him using the philosopher's
stone I'm responsible.
I did this when I was Doctor alchemy and then
later something to remember for future episode.
It's really important is one more metahuman
husk out there somewhere that they have to
track down.
He tried to do it by himself but the whole
theme of the episode was working together.
Meaning that things will probably go really
badly if he tries to do that by himself.
So just remember that for the future but the
big thing is Luigi's restaurant.
It's part of the board of irises death of
things that they're trying to change Iris's
freaking out because not everything is being
wiped off the board, so it just a way to show
you that even though they are able to change
some things in the future they will be able
to change every single thing, so that'll come
back around at the end of the video when I
talk about some of my bigger WTF's like killer
Frost and Doctor alchemy.
So just remember that not everything is going
to be undone though still be some bad things
happening to people the prophecy will still
come true savitar prophecy little be a little
bit different number seven was Cecile's daughter
just being really awkward and funny making
Joe pick between Wally and Barry who is the
better one.
You know who's the real hero don't do it.
It's a trap.
So there were a couple times in the episode
where they made it seem like kid flash was
getting all the glory and people were forgetting
about how awesome Barry is, but then there
were some moments at the end that took that
back.
So they balance the scales a little bit, they
just want to show you that there are people
that are really jazzed up about kid flash,
but they haven't forgotten about Barry Barry
is still the main attraction kid flash still
has a lot to learn but I was expecting some
big twist with Cecile's daughter, but it turns
out that she just like a normal kid.
But they did say that she be coming back in
a month me that's like a couple more episodes,
so should be back before the end of the season
number six is all the Julian Caitlin CSI scenes
early on the episode were he's a total deuce
to her.
So I love all these scenes I think we've seen
more of Caitlin doing actual CSI biology work
which is her chosen profession she's a biologist
we've seen her do more of that in the last
couple of episodes than in any previous season
so one of the things they do.
Each new season is because they're still in
star labs they try to do new set, so like
the medical lab looks very different from
previous season so whatever ends up happening
at the end of the season going into season
four were still at star labs will have different
sets, but will slough some of the old favorites
to like the so have the portal room to earth
two though probably keep the speed lab, but
they'll be some other places inside star labs
we haven't been before number five Barry is
having trouble training Wally he just keeps
running into the board bouncing off trying
to phase it's not working Barry wonders what
eobard Thawne did to train him and I love
the crack that Cisco made he says will he
out about 15 years, to plan how he was going
to train you, just reminding you that that
version of wells had to wait that long for
Barry to get his powers so that he could train
them to use his power to get himself back
to the future but they did a good job in the
episode of showing you some of Wally's frustration
like he's really good at straight-line speed
not really great with the more nuanced skills
that he is smart enough to understand quantum
theory, when they have survived into a flashpoint
universe.
So what you have here is Barry learning to
be a teacher Jay Garrick style, he needs to
be an inspiration to the people he is teaching
not just somebody who gives them assignments
to complete everybody's had a teacher like
that.
Just give me the homework and then you have
other teachers who are amazing because they
inspire you to be better.
So there's going to be a lot more of this
the rest of the season and in all the future
seasons if we ever get more speedsters like
a lot of people want to see Bart.
There is good have to be able to be the Jay
Garrick to others speedsters.
The way the Jay Garrick helps him, so number
four is via being a flashpoint universe.
So you have to keep in mind that they're not
via being what flashpoint was there's an infinite
number of universes out there.
A lot of you asked me that question.
So in the flash TV show there are infinite
universes.
So they 51 where Barry did not undo flashpoint
just to find out who the last person Clive
York and is going after so they find her in
they track her down, but I just love the idea
of Leo Cisco's teasing abilities that he doesn't
have yet Gypsy saying that he has all these
things that he doesn't even know that he can
do yet.
So he's actually one of the most powerful
metahuman's on the planet, he just doesn't
know it yet he could actually divide the planet
apart.
That's how powerful he is, he can cut speedsters
off from the speed force many he could turn
their powers off any as Tara kinesis.
Meaning he can move the earth around telekinetic
lady, but the other smaller one that's a little
more useful is that he can also become undetectable
to security cameras.
So there all kinds of abilities that they
can roll out in future seasons.
Maybe because he is the costume and the goblets
now will see another new Cisco power before
the end of the season but I almost forgot
when he vibe is that other flashpoint universe
Alex dessert Julio Mendez is still alive because
remember he was the police captain during
flashpoint.
He was from the original 1990s flash series.
He was there version of Cisco on that TV show.
So it's always fun to see them come back I
saw a bunch of you are bummed out when they
kill them off during the episode, but there's
so many ways they can bring him back he can
come back during flashbacks from alternate
universes like he did in this episode, so
he can still come guest star on the TV show
but as always fun to see those older characters
come on the modern TV show number three is
Julia talking Caitlin down from killer Frost
before she just lets Iris die.
So the whole thing with Caitlin here is that
is like this really nuanced you superpowers
you notice that was a thing in the episode
teaching Wally to use his powers in a really
nuanced way.
Caitlin learning to use her powers with a
lot more control that will be useful when
they try to fight savitar at the end of the
season so Caitlin starts to go more and more
killer Frost because Iris is getting worse
and worse.
So she starts speaking with her voice Julian
has to undo ship by himself and talk her down,
which circling back around to the flash prophecy
about what I said earlier Julian feels like
he's week he was able to fight savitar's control.
But then later at the end of the episode.
She invites him out for drinks he tries to
tell them that hey you're not week.
So it seems like the kind of a pair now but
what might end up happening before the end
of the season is that they both end up going
bad and running off together which is a funny
thought.
I don't think they're going anywhere, but
I do think that were gonna see full-blown
killer Frost again before the end of the season
and Doctor alchemy will have something to
do with savitar coming back into the real
world.
So just because it seems like they did really
good in this episode doesn't mean like they
won't go off the deep end again before the
end of the season so number two was a big
train save you have a big win for kid flash
phasing his blood into Clive York and and
Barry phasing the train just another flash
power that you didn't know that he had which
is actually something that they borrowed from
the new 52 comics of the flash run except
the only difference is that he faced an airplane
but is exact same thing where he faces this
giant craft of people, so they'll be all kinds
of things that they do in future seasons like
this Cisco learning new powers the flash learning
new powers Jay Garrick is really where that
comes in Barry's really scientific, but a
lot of times you just have to watch somebody
else do something, so Jay Garrick Jesse quick
bill.
The other speedsters that they run into that
unit, just because they think differently
they thought of a different use for the speed
force, so they'll teach that to Barry Wally,
everybody will work together because that
was the big theme of the episode Joe had that
big speech at the end race that were all good
have to up our game, each of the people who
had a big win in the episode only did so because
they had help from someone else like Wally
only knew what to do because Barry told him
what to do Caitlin was only able to help Iris
because Julian helped her.
So that's a really important clue for how
they're going to save Iris and defeat's savitar
together which I feel like everybody knew
but sometimes you just need the characters
to actually say that to foreshadow like hey
were actually can have to do this together.
No one person is going to be able to save
Iris on their own.
It's good have to be all of us working together
in a no really ominous Joe at the end was
asking Barry about the savitar prophecy is
she the one is gonna die.
Barry nods his head yes that is not necessarily
true they can change the future but I don't
think that they're going to change savitar's
prophecy.
Someone will still die.
Someone will still suffer a fate worse than
death, etc., so more and more I'm thinking
that either Julian or HR are going to be the
ones to die because their swords the odd man
out on the team to redeeming themselves like
Julian is having this big arc where he used
to be this terrible person doing terrible
things for savitar now he's turning into a
good person whom yank the rug right out from
under you and HR is trying to do the same
thing make his life have meaning once he achieves
that.
What would be the most WTF thing you do you
kill them off.
So they of the two people that are at the
top of my deathless this season, but my number
one WTF is obviously the gorilla Grodd teaser
at the end always so happy that he faces and
blew out pops Jesse quick my father's been
captured and taken to gorilla city.
Just explain the gorilla city episode.
It's gonna be a two-parter is just like last
year with it in the two-part earth two episode.
So will probably see some familiar characters.
But it'll be all about gorilla city, so it
won't start for another two weeks of the flash
is on break next week I'll still do bonus
videos like a normally would, but let me know
in the comments what are you most excited
about and what you think the next new powers
that they're going to demonstrate is Cisco
needs a new power and Barry and Wally need
new powers to like what you think the next
thing they're going to do is the next video
I post will be the trailer for that gorilla
city episode.
I'll explain a little bit more about gorilla
city in the comics and was going on with Solovar
because they're introducing that character
then I'll post my legends of tomorrow episode
video, but congratulations to the new flash
ring giveaway winner, it's Albie.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll announce the winner when I post
that flash trailer video in the morning.
So get hype is can be so awesome while you
wait for that you can click here for the iron
fist trailer and you can click here to learn
what the different colors of flash lightning
the thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you in the next video!